"Barbie" had actors lining up to
play Kens, but it didn't work out
for everyone for a surprising reason.
Who backed away from the part, and why?
It's likely not a huge surprise
that, when it was announced that
Oscar-nominated writer-director Greta
Gerwig was making a "Barbie" movie,
actors across Hollywood wanted to get involved
right away. "Vanity Fair" spoke to two of the
movie's casting directors, Lucy Bevan and Allison
Jones, to dig deeper into how the candy-coated,
fiercely feminist film managed to score
its star-studded lineup. As it turns out,
we missed out on three potential Kens — Bowen
Yang, Dan Levy, and Ben Platt all wanted to
play Kens, but couldn't make it work due to
COVID-19 restrictions in place during filming.
"What do I have to do?"
"You have to go to the real world."
While "Barbie" was in production, the
entire cast had to commit to staying
in London for the entirety of shoot, due
to strict COVID-19 protocols — and Yang,
Levy, and Platt couldn't make the
commitment, for a variety of reasons.
It's easy enough to guess why — Yang is a
cast member on "Saturday Night Live," Dan
Levy just briefly worked on "The Idol,"
and Platt is currently starring in "Parade"
on Broadway as well as the new film "Theater
Camp." Still, the casting directors said those
actors were quite upset that they couldn't
make it work. Jones told "Vanity Fair,"
"They were, I'm not kidding,
really bummed they couldn't do it."
According to the "Vanity Fair" piece, Ken
wasn't the only part in "Barbie" being
fought over in Hollywood. Incredibly,
the role of Allan — "Ken's buddy" who,
in doll form, fits into all of Ken's
same clothes — was a hot ticket as well,
and at first, Jonathan Groff, known for
projects like "Mindhunter," "Looking,"
and "Frozen," really, really wanted to
play the amorphous blob known as Allan.
Unfortunately for Groff, he suffered the same fate
as the others. Jones isn't specific about whether
or not Groff was simply auditioning himself for
the part or actually in talks further down the
line, but she does say that, eventually, Groff
reached out and said he couldn't make London work.
The role of Allan ultimately went to
Scott Pilgrim himself, Michael Cera,
and with all due respect to Groff, Cera
couldn't be more perfect in the role.
Described by "Vulture's" Jen Chaney as, quote,
"a vibe, if having no vibe counts as a vibe,"
Allan is just kind of there. Cera, a master
of quiet deadpan, completely nails the part.
"Humans! We're fine!"
"And Allan!"
So how did Bevan and Jones settle on
the Kens and Barbies who ended up in
the movie? When it came to the Kens, Bevan said,
"They were definitely really different,
but they had to feel like a cohesive group.
You wanted to cast people who were really
going to get on and be great and enjoy it."
Based on the end result, it seems like that's
exactly what happened; "Barbie" is a film that,
even in its most emotional moments,
overflows with uninhibited joy.
Unsurprisingly, Gerwig was also
closely involved in casting;
Bevan says she showed the casting directors
old illustrations of classic Barbie and Ken
dolls to narrow down a certain look, but the
personality was still paramount. Bevan said,
"She really wanted to get to know them as people.
That was very important to her. On the key Barbie
and Ken roles, she got a very good idea of
what an actor was like from talking to them."
Here's the good news: Marvel's Simu Liu
really, really wanted a part in the movie,
and he ended up playing the main nemesis
and eventual ally to Gosling's main Ken.
"I'll beach off with you any day, Ken."
"Barbie" is in theaters now.